lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
resolver con integración por parte es un
ejemplo muy divertido es un ejemplo muy
divertido pues es estos ejemplos que
tienen como que un truquito que siempre
los maestros ponen en los exámenes de
cálculo que son muy difíciles o bien que
si vas a competencias de cálculo te lo
puedes encontrar
yo solía ir a competencias de cálculo
pero cuando era chiquito no era un niño
genial
más bien como que me gustaba hacer las
matemáticas y así pero si tengo que
aceptar que pues si participaba en
concursos y así pero bueno de cualquier
forma este es un ejercicio divertido
porque realmente nunca tenemos que
evaluar la integral sino que más bien
como que regresamos a ella de una manera
sorpresiva es un clásico es un clásico
entonces ahí te vas supongamos que
tenemos la integral que tenemos la
integral de ea la equis y tal vez nunca
hayas escuchado a nadie decir que un
problema de matemáticas es un clásico
verdad pero con un poco de suerte espero
transmitir de esta pasión por las
matemáticas para que también pienses que
esto es un clásico entonces tenemos ea
la equis por coseno de x
de x
creo que ya más o menos ves qué va a
pasar en esta verdad estas dos ya son
funciones muy divertidas porque cuando
derivamos sea la x o la anti derivamos
se queda como ea la x coseno de x cuando
la derivamos se hace menos en de x la
derivamos otra vez se hace menos coseno
de x luego seno de xy a la cuarta
regresamos a coseno de x entonces este
ciclo si este ciclo lo mismo pasa con la
anti derivada no es tan cool como era la
equis pero si se cicla digamos cada que
tomas cuatro veces la derivada entonces
pues estas dos funciones aquí las dos
son muy buenas son son hacen cosas muy
divertidas derivando a integrando
entonces pues vamos a ver qué va a pasar
con esto qué va a pasar con esto y con
la integración por partes entonces ahí
te va siempre que hacemos integración
por partes tenemos que decidir quién es
que prima y quiénes efe
voy a poner que era la x es g prima de x
a lo mejor se puede hacer de la otra
forma no se tendría que pensarlo y pues
ya teníamos que intentarlo a ver qué
pasa pero bueno vamos a hacerlo de esta
forma ahorita a coste no vamos a ponerle
fx sale entonces éste se prima entonces
para inter
por partes que tenemos que hacer tenemos
que tomar las dos funciones originales y
multiplicar las que prima es a la x
entonces su anti derivada o sea su
primitiva es simplemente a la x es lo
que platicamos al principio verdad
entonces nos queda
a la equis
aquí o sea es la primitiva pero pues
como es real x es la misma además
tenemos que poner cosa en equis y hay
que restar la integral
y una vez más tenemos que poner la
primitiva de g prima de x es decir
tenemos que poner g prima del perdón de
x bueno da lo mismo verdad ósea britania
gxg prima de x son lo mismo que da a la
x ahorita los dos tanto como g prima
zone a la x pero eso hay que
multiplicarlo o sea aquí este queda a la
equis y hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de fx es decir la derivada de
coseno de x la derivada de jose no es
menos e no voy a poner por aquí el seno
de x va a poner de xy me falta un menos
si pongo el menos aquí queda feo si
pongo el menos acá también queda feo
entonces voy a ponerlo aquí afuera el
menos con el menos se hace más y
entonces ya hacemos que un poquito más
bonito entonces la integral de al x josé
9 x de x es igual a la x coseno de x más
la integral de ea la x seno de x
a ver entonces déjame pasar para acá a
lo mejor debería de marcar un poco
quiénes gdx y quiénes fx esto aquí
fíjate que es la anti derivada la anti
derivada ésta es la anti derivada
también es más este aquí el que prima
este de aquí el gx
este de aquí también es gdx
entonces una vez más nos enfrentamos a
un problema que parece ser que va a ser
resuelto por partes entonces no se ve
muy claro todavía que hemos hecho algún
progreso pero vamos a integrar por
partes una vez más a ver qué pasa sale
entonces déjame déjame reescribir aquí
abajo en escribir aquí abajo
queda a ver qué da a la x coseno de x
más
y ahora vamos a hacer integral por
partes una vez más voy a abrir un
paréntesis grande entonces ahora en esta
nueva ronda de integración por partes
ahora a la x en la primer ronda a la x
será gdx pero en esta nueva ronda a la x
dentro de esta integral va a ser g prima
de x
verdad claro otra vez la deriva de la
derivada va a ser ea la equis pero seno
de que va a ser fx va a ser nuestra
nueva nuestra nueva nuestras nuevas
funciones para integrar por partes
entonces tenemos que poner fx por gd x
verdad que ya cuando estamos ya cuando
estamos resolviendo entonces la anti
derivada de ea la x es otra vez a la x
entonces pongo a la equis y lo tenemos
que poner por seno de x
y tenemos que restar tenemos que restar
la integral
la integral de la primitiva de ea la
equis
a la equis y luego la derivada de fx fx
s de x entonces la derivada es coseno de
x
de x
ahí está vamos a ver si realmente
estamos haciendo algo parece ser que
seguimos sumando términos y haciendo las
cosas complicadas pero para realmente
ver si estamos avanzando no voy a
reescribir la expresión para que dé un
poco más claro lo que estamos haciendo
entonces a ver tenemos déjame cambiar de
color voy a usar pues voy a utilizar
este azul
tenemos a la equis coseno de x de x es
igual
y ahora vamos a regresar al naranja es
igual a a la x coseno dx
y podemos simplemente ignorar este
paréntesis porque aquí afuera hay un más
entonces es simplemente a la equis cosa
x más a la x seno de x
- menos la integral de ea la x
el seno de x de x
ahora a lo mejor debe estar pensando que
aquí yo cambian los colores
arbitrariamente sin embargo si hay una
razón por la cual cambie de colores
puedes ver cuáles hay algo que vean
sospechoso sí exactamente fíjate que lo
que puse en azul a la derecha es el
negativo de la expresión azul en la
izquierda entonces aquí es la parte
súper padre del asunto podemos sumar
este término a ambos lados de la
ecuación es decir podemos pasarlo al
lado izquierdo sumando y si hacemos eso
y lo pasamos de este lado de la ecuación
que pasa ahora tenemos dos veces la
integral de a la x coseno xx déjame
escribirlo por aquí entonces saber nos
queda a la x coseno de x v x + porque
estábamos pasando este término de este
lado más que a la x coseno de x
de equis y eso es simplemente lo mismo
que dos veces la integral de ea la x
coseno de x v x
y eso es igual a este otro término eso
es igual si creo que se le está acabando
un poco el espacio a la equis coseno de
x más a la x cnv x sin ya quedó muy
hecho bolas bueno pero lo único que
tengo que hacer para resolver esto
integral es dividir entre dos y
terminamos eso va a estar súper padre
déjame escribirlo por aquí abajo vamos a
esperar que sí me quepa por aquí a ver
entonces obtenemos que la integral de la
x 12 de x v x
es igual
y vamos a ponerlo así con es igual a la
equis
kosen de x
más a la x c x
y entre 2
a mí me parece que esto está súper padre
esto es como súper elegante fíjate como
la integral por partes nos permite hacer
un poco de truquitos algebraicos para
pasar como para regresar el problema
original pero con otro signo de modo que
como que se ciclo y podemos juntar dos
de los que queremos y ya despejar lo es
algo súper padre como que simplemente al
final queda resuelto como por arte de
magia y más aún fíjate otra cosa que
está padre es que ya que resolvemos la
integral el resultado es una expresión
muy limpia la anti derivada de ea la x
coseno de x otra vez en olvido almacén
pero bueno la que estaba así lo que está
padre es que la integral de la x coseno
de x es esta expresión que es muy
simétrica es la x coseno de x más la xx
entre 2 es el promedio de una expresión
que tiene funciones trigonométricas y a
la x espero que te haya gustado mucho
este truco y que ya más o menos veas por
qué a este problema le llaman un clásico
y espero también haberse contagiado un
poquito de esta pasión que tengo por las
matemáticas nos vemos en siguientes
vídeos y ojalá sí
encontrando problemas clásicos y estos
trucos tan elegantes hasta la próxima